attempting a 72-hour fast 14 hours in
I'm at the gym to hit a leg day before I
lose too much energy I was so hungry
after that we're about 24 hours in I'm
going to bed so early comes in waves and
right now I'm real hungry I got so dizzy
I collapsed why why why she describes
feeling so hungry dizzy collapsing and
having blue balls for food when she goes
grocery shopping assumingly referring to
the obsessive thoughts that she was
having about food while not being able
to eat yes we know that there are likely
benefits to water fasts up to 72 hours
so most of the data we do have on said
benefits are either in rats or our trans
get in short-term but it's very hard to
measure the long-term benefits against
the risks and cost of doing something
like this even if there were a ton of
benefits I think that chronicling this
miserable Journey without medical
supervision insinuating like a no pain
no gain attitude in front of potentially
millions of vulnerable young eyeballs is
irresponsible at best and super super
dangerous at worst